[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم مساء الخير معالي
الدكتور مساء النور هل من المبكر معالي
الدكتور ان اسال حضرتك عن حصاد طوفان
الاقصى والنتائج اللي ترتبت على هذا الحدث
الكبير اللي ترتب عليه حرب اسرائيليه على
قطار غزه ام ان يعني نحتاج الى وقت وقت
اطول حتى نفهم النتائج بعيده الامد لعمليه
طوفان الاقصى ا الحقيقه اشكرك يا استاذ
سيد على اثاره هذا الموضوع لانه من المؤكد
وان كانت النتائج النهائيه لطوفان الاقصى
لم تحسم بعد لكن من المؤكد انه افضى الى
عدد من النتائج الاكيده حتى ولم تتجسد بعد
على ارض الواقع اذا بدانا باسرائيل كما
قلت كم من وا كم من النتائج حدثت ويمكن ان
تحدث اول شيء شديد الوضوح المساس بالهيبه
الاسرائيليه والمكانه الاسرائيليه هذا
المساس سبق ان حدث بوضوح في حرب اكتوبر
73 وهو يتكرر
في حرب اكتوبر 2023 50 سنه وبينهما
وبينهما حرب 2006 في لبنان وبينهما 2006
اذا نحن بصدد تشكيل نموذج تاريخي ان
اسرائيل كيان عادي يمكن ضربه وايلام
وهزيمته وبعدين اذا كان حرب اكتوبر كانت
فعلا حربا عربيه اسرائيليه بمعنى مصر مصر
وسوريا بساعه صفر واحده تسع دول عربيه على
جبهتي القتال بقوات مسلحه الدول المصدره
للبترول تستخدم سلاح البترول اليمن مصر
تنسق معها من اجل اغلاق مضيق باب المندب
حرب عربيه اسرائيليه كامله اسرائيل الان
تواجه المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
غزه كما واجهت المقاومه اللبنانيه في 2006
فالان اصبح يعني الدرس شديد الوضوح اول
اول شيء في اسرائيل اسرائيل لم تعد هذا
الكيان الذي لا يقهر يعني الشيء الثاني ان
اسرائيل تحكمها الان هو طبعا دلوقتي حكومه
وحده وطنيه لكن الحكومه التي حضرت هذه
الضربه القاسمه كانت اشد الحكومات
الاسرائيليه تطرفا التي يدعو بعض بعض
اعضائها الى حرق القرى الاسرائيليه القرى
العربيه القرى الفلسطينيه
ويمارس المستوطنون همجيه في مواجهه
الفلسطينيين يحرقون مزارعهم وسياراتهم
ويقتحمون بيوتهم وتخرج المصلين من المسجد
الاقصى ويقتحم المستوطنون ممارسات يعني
غير مسبوقه
وشديده التط
في عهد هذه الحكومه حدث اكبر خرق للامن
الاسرائيلي واقول انه اكبر خرق لماذا لانه
حدث من جزء من المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهي
المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في غزه فانا اتصور ان الاثر
الاكيد لطوفان الاقصى سوف يكون اسقاط هذه
الحكومه هي اولا ضم اليها اخرون لكي تصبح
حكومه وحده وطنيه لكن انا تقديري انه
اسقاط هذه الحكومه حتمي ان لم يكن فورا
ففي اول انتخابات طب سؤال لو له اجابه
سريعه عشان مقطعش حبل افكار حضرتك هو يعني
هذا امر يجب ان نبتهج به يعني نفترض سخرت
حكومه نتنياهو مع هذه الحكومات يعني هل
يعني بنتعشى ان تييجي حكومه تبقى
يعني نتفائل بوجودها كويس جدا هذا السؤال
لانه نتعشى
ان تاتي حكومه اعقل على على الاقل لا يوجد
فيها امثال بنج وفير وسنتر والناس دي فعلى
الاقل وقد نذكر ان لابيد عندما كان قائما
او رئيسا للوزاره تحدث عن حل الدولتين كما
توصل اسحاق رابين الى اتفاق اسلو فرغم
الوحده في السياسه الاسرائيليه والرغبه في
حمايه الكيان الاسرائ
الا انه ممكن ان تكون هناك حكومه افضل من
حكومه لكن هذا ليس هو
التاثير
الوحيد نحن منذ ايام نشاهد مظاهرات ذوي
الاسرى والرهائن في قطاع غزه ويتهمون بحق
نتنياهو انه المسؤول ويدعونه للاستقاله
اذا هناك حراك سياسي اسرائيلي
مهم
التاثير الثث انه بعيدا بقى عن الحكومه
وكده يعني انه من الممكن ان نفترض وهذه
الاصوات ظهرت في الصحافه الاسرائيليه وفي
الحراك المجتمعي الاسرائيلي انه اصوات
تبدا في الحديث عن مستقبل اسرائيل وانه من
الممكن ان نعود خصوصا المهاجرين الح نرحل
عن اسرائيل واخيرا وليس اخرا التاثير
الاقتصادي الذي يعني قد يكون اكثر مما
نتوقع لان هناك تاثيرا هائلا على السياحه
هناك تاثيرا على البورصه هناك تاثير على
ا اسف على السياحه وعلى البورصه اه
التكاليف المباشره للحرب تخيل حضرتك كم
هذه طبعا الولايات المتحده جاهزه تعوض
انما ولو ما هي برض الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عندها ازمه ماليه والكونجرس كان
في اخر ميزانيه مؤقته فيدراليه قال بشرط
ان يكون فيها مساعدات لاوكرانيا
فالمسالة يمكن ان يحدث للاقتصاد
الاسرائيلي سياحه وتوقف عن العمل ووى اخره
لاول مره هناك اجلاء تام يعني مع كل
التعاطف مع اهلنا في غزه في غزه الذين لا
يجدون ماوى والذين ي يقيمون في خيام اقل
ما توصف به انها غير صالحه وغير لائقه فان
هناك ايضا نزوحا في اسرائيل وهناك اخلاء
للمستوطنات في اسرائيل وهناك اخلاء لمدن
زي عسقلان في اسرائيل فيعني هذا الجو
العام اتصور انه طوفان الاقصى احدثه
وانتهى الامر يعني لكي اكون صريحا حتى لو
لا قدر الله انتهى طوفان الاقصى وان شاء
الله لا يحدث هذا بان سيطرت اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه بالكامل فان الاثر قد وقع ولا
رجعه فيه ا طبعا علي ان اكون يعني طبعا
منصفا انه في اخرين اساتذه وزملاء لحضرتك
يخالفوه ال الراي ولكن على الاقل هذا هو
راي حضرتك انه قدر الطوفان الاقصى يحقق
نوعا من الردع ويخلي الاسرائيليين يجروا
في حساباتهم او يضعوا في حساباتهم انه مش
كل افعالهم لن تكون بلا رد فعل انا بيحضر
ني كلام حضرتك على الاثر الا اقتصادي كلمه
الفريق الشاذلي اللي كان رئيس اركان حرب
القوات المسلحه اثناء حرب 73 انا بعرفه
طبعا هو علم في العسكريه المصريه لكن ربما
غير المصريين لا يعلموه كان دايما يقول ان
الاسرائيليين لهم مقتل واحد الخسائر
البشريه ثانيا طول امد الحرب والاثنين
مرتبطين بالعنصر البشري لا يتحملون حربا
تقع فيهم خسائر كبيره لانه عددهم في
النهايه محدود عدد كل اليهود اللي في
العالم في اخر تقدير حوالي 15 مليون عدد
اليهود اللي موجود في الاراضي المحتله
حوالي 7 مليون وبالتالي فهم يعني حساسين
تجاه الخسائر البشريه طول امد الحرب برض
مرتبط انه ما عندوش استعداد لان الجيش
عنده بيقوم على عمليه الاستدعاء وعمليه
الاستدعاء دي
اذكر اصدقائنا المتابعين انه كان احد
اسباب عدم استجابه جولد مائير للتحذيرات
اللي قبل 73 هي خوفها من الاستدعاء
المتكرر اللي بياثر على الاقتصاد
الاسرائيلي لان الجنود هم نفسهم المهندسين
والدكاتره والعمال تمام ف انا اسف ان انا
اط لا لا تمام يا استاذ سيد واريد ان
استكمل ما ذكرته حضرتك انه احنا في حرب
اكتوبر في الايام الاخيره للحرب بدا يظهر
مقاتلون عواجيز اذا جاز التعبير اه لانه
يعني خلاص كم الخسائر البشريه زاد
وبالتالي رفع سن الاستدعاء
الملاحظه الثانيه تعقيبا على كلامك يا
استاذ سيد انه اذا صحت التوقعات فان حرب
طوفان الاقصى قد تكون اطول الحروب العربيه
الاسرائيليه يعني عدوان يونيو استغرق
اياما حرب اكتوبر ثلاثه ا اسابيع عدوان
2006 زاد عن شهر بايام اذا صح هذا ف هذا
موقف غير مسبوق تواجهه اسرائيل انه اقل
التوقعات اللي بيقولوها الاسرائيليين
والقياده العسكريه انه شهرين ثلاثه اخرين
بيتحدث سرا ان العمليه علشان تتم المهمه
المعلنه وهو القضاء على حماس قد تستغرق
سنوات ولكني اضيف انه حتى لو انتهت الحرب
اليوم فان الخسائر جسيمه طيب هذا عن الاثر
على اسرائيل حضك تحب تضيف حاجه ثانيه ولا
ننتقل طيب بالنسبه ل للاثر على الساحه
العربيه لا انا يعني اسمح لي ان ابدا
بالاثر على فلسطين على فلسطين افضل لانه
طبعا هذا من نوع الاثار التي ستتوقف على
النتيجه النهائيه
ل الحرب الدائره الان لانه لو استطاعت
حماس الصمود في وجه الغزو البري ان شاء
الله كما صمد حزب الله في وجه عدوان 2006
اتصور ان الخريطه الفلسطينيه سيكون من
المؤكد ان تتغير لانه حتى الان نعلم ان
حماس ليست داخله ضمن منظمه التحرير
الفلسطينيه وكان هناك مفاوضات وشروط
واشياء من هذا القبيل لكن المهمه لم تنجز
ليست جزءا من السلطه الفلسطينيه اللي
بيعترف بها العالم طبعا وبالتالي لو
استطاعت ان تصمد كسمو حزب الله في وجه
عدوان 2006 فان الخريطه الفلسطينيه
الداخليه سوف تتغير ا بالتاكيد اذا حدث لا
قدر الله ان حماس يعني هزمت في هذه الحرب
بمعنى ان اسرائيل تمكنت من السيطره على
قطاع غزه وهذا في تقديري لن يحدث وان حدث
فستكون التكلفه هائله فان على
الاسرائيليين ولا على على الاسرائيليين
على الاسرائيليين طبعا نعم فانه من الممكن
استمرار الصيغ الحاليه ولكن بالتاكيد ليس
بنفس المضمون يعني من الممكن استمرار صيغه
السلطه الفلسطينيه وما الى هذا ولكن ليس
بهذا المضمون لانه ليس من المعقول ان تدفع
كل هذه التضحيات وتبقى الامور على ما هي
اله هتواجه اصلا تحديات كبيره وكان انا
حابب اطرح على حضرتك سؤال بس يمكن المره
دي الوقت لا يتسع هو الخيارات اللي لامام
السلطه التي يقودها الرئيس محمود عباس ابو
مازن في مواجهه اسرائيل ما هو لازم
يتحركوا مش معقوله هيفضل طول الوقت بس
عمليه ادانه ا ف ايه هي الخيارات اللي
قدامهم هل ممكن يلجوا الى خيارات بقى اللي
بيسموها يعني
الخيارات الاعلى السقف انه يحل السلطه انه
يذهبوا الى الامم المتحده اعتقد الاجابه
ممكن يتسع نخليها الحلقه انيه ولا في
اجابات سريعه لا ممكن بس اجابه سريعه
لنستكمل الموضوع لكن المساله شديده
التعقيد هي المعضله الرئيسيه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه ان النهج الذي اتبعته بموجب
اتفاقيه اسلو لم يثمر اي شيء تمام لم يثمر
حتى السلطه الموجوده معروف ان اسرائيل
بتنته كها في اي وقت وتدخل ما تشاء من
الاراضي اللي المفروض ان السلطه بتسيطر
عليها الى اخره ف ف اذا لا قدر
الله سيطره اسرائيل على قطاع غزه ستكون
هناك معضله حقيقيه افضل تاجيل التفكير
فيها لانه ان شاء الله مازل ما زلت يعني
عندي امل قوي في ان هذا لن يحدث لانه بعد
السيطره الاسرائيليه هل ستتحول اسرائيل
مره اخرى الى قوه احتلال وكيف
تدير ومعضل اعاده الاعمار الرهيبه التي
تسببت فيها اسرائيل اشياء
شديده التعقيد ف ما اقصده انه لو ان يعني
داعيا دعى السلطه الفلسطينيه الى ان تتولى
الامور في غزه بالاضافه الى الضفه هذه في
حد ذاتها معضله معضله كبيره جدا ان تقبل
السلطه ان هي تيجي زي ما بيقولوا كده على
ظهر الدبابه الاسرائيليه طيب عموما اذا
تركنا الجانب الفلسطيني وتحدثنا عن اثار
طوفان الاقصى على الساحه العربيه
شوف يا استاذ سيد انا بالنسبه للساحه
العربيه لست متاكدا الا من امرين حدث
بالفعل الامر الاول انه بالتاكيد طوفان
الاقصى سيكون له تاثير سلبي على التطبيع
واذا اذا كان من الصعوبه بمكان ان نتخيل
او نتاكد من العوده عن التطبيع بالنسبه
للدول الداخله فيه فانه مما لا شك فيه في
تقديري ان التطبيع القادم سوف يواجه
بصعوبات هائله يعني لا اتصور
ان السعوديه وهي حريصه على الحق العربي
والفلسطيني سوف تستمر او تستانف مفاوضات
التطبيع لانه يعني السعوديه كانت تطلب
مطالب معينه جزء منها لها في مواجهه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وجزء منها
للشعب الفلسطيني هذه المطالب تغيرت تماما
بعد بعد التدمير الهائل الذي
شهدناه في غزه فانا اتصور انه من المؤكد
ان مسيره التطبيع
ستصبح شديده التعثر بعد
طوفان الاقصى قبل حرك تتكلم على الامر
الثاني بس اذكر المتابعين ان كان ما تسرب
لوسائل الاعلام نقلا عن مصادر امريكيه
واسرائيليه لان السعود لا يتحدثون
السعوديه اشترطت لتحقيق التطبيع مجموعه من
المطالب خاصه بها ممكن ترجعوا لحلقات سوف
اضع لكم رابطها لكن فيما يتعلق
بالفلسطينيين اشترطت ان يحصل الفلسطينيون
على دولتهم شكل الدوله كان محل تفاوض انما
على الاقل كان في اصرار من السعوديه على
ان يكون هناك امل للحفاظ على ولو الحد
الادنى للحقوق الفلسطينيه اتفضل يا فندم
ده صحيح النقطه الثانيه المهمه جدا على
صعيد النظام العربي ان طوفان الاقصى اثبت
ان الجماهير العربيه ما زالت متمسكه
بالقضيه الفلسطينيه وهذا في منتهى الاهميه
لانه مهما تراجع دور الجماهير في السياسات
الرسميه لابد وان يؤخذ في الحسبان يعني
نشوف مثلا حجم التظاهرات التي تمت في دوله
ك المغرب
ونشوف مثلا مدى تفاعل الراي العام المصري
مع الاشقاء
الفلسطينيين في غزه وبالتالي هذه حقيقه
جديده وطبعا في دول عربيه كثيره يعني لا
يعني يعني لا تعد ولا تحصى يعني عديد من
الدول العربيه شهد تحركات جماهيريه حقيقيه
وبالتالي هذا يطمئنني لانه ضمان ضد اختفاء
القضيه الفلسطينيه
عربيا القضيه الفلسطينيه كان ممكن ان
تختفي عربيا بسياسات اسرايل كانوا بيرنوا
على كده انه يعني تصور نتنياهو اللي من
سنوات انه سوف سوف نتقدم على صعيد التطبيع
مع الدول العربيه من قبيل التعاون في
مقابل التعاون والسلام في مقابل السلام
بعيدا عن بعيدا وتبقى القضيه الفلسطينيه
على ما هي عليه هذا السيناريو اعتقد انه
احد السيناريوهات التي ان لم يكن طوفان
الاقصى قد اسقطها تماما فعلى الاقل اصابها
بعطب شديد على الساحه العربيه هي الايرن
يا معالي الدكتور او المفارقه الغريبه
اللي ممكن يعني الواحد يتاملها بعدين ان
الراجل اللي سع سنين طويله جدا منذ ان ظهر
للساحه السياسيه في 2009 انه يحقق تطبيع
وعلاقات مع كل الدول العربيه مع اصراره
على انها انه ليس شرطا لتحقيق ذلك انه
يعطي الفلسطينين حقوقهم هو سياسته اللي
ادت الى افشال يعني هذا المخطط انه
الاصرار عليه والتمادي فيه ادى الى احياء
القضيه الفلسطينيه ثاني والتعاطف معهم مره
ثانيه على المستوى الشعبي اللي بيكبر
القيادات السياسيه ان تستجيب يعني وهذا
يتسق مع منطق التاريخ ومنطق حركات التحرر
الوطني طيب يا معالي الدكتور على ده على
المستوى العربي ده على المستوى العرب هل
على المستوى الدولي في اثار لطوفان الاقصى
يعني هو طبعا نحن نلاحظ
السياسات المغالي في انحيازها لاسرائيل
بشكل غير مسبوق وهذا نعرفه وليس من
تاثيرات طوفان الاقصى لكن طوفان الاقصى
كان كاشفا لها التماهي التام مع اسرائيل
لدرجه ان دوله كفرنسا هي
يعني منشا الدفاع عن الحريه تفرض عقوبه
السجن على من يتظاهر لصالح فلسطين او من
يكتب تويتا لصالح فلسطين او على من يرفع
عمل فلسطين اشياء لا تصدق وبالتالي هذا
نعرفه ما
هو الشيء الذي يعني اعتقد انه حدث بالفعل
ولو كارها اسات انه كم الجرائم
الاسرائيليه في غزه الصور التي نشاهدها
يوما بعد يوم الفيديوهات ووى اخره من
الواضح انه كان له تاثير غير مسبوق على
الراي العام العالمي انا كل يوم يصلني
حوالي ثلاث او اربع فيديوهات اوروبيه او
امريكيه او او الى اخره دفاع مطلق عن غزه
واهلها انا طبعا لا اعلم مدى وزن هذه
المواقف ولكنها ظرت وتتطور
وتزيد اكثر من هذا
شاهدت شريطي شريطي
فيديو ليهود
امريكيين شريط منهم يقول ليس باسمنا يعني
يا اسرائيل اللي بتعمليه ده لا
تفعليه ومظاهره اخرى يعني
شديده التطرف في الدفاع عن الحق الفلسطيني
وهذا نعلمه جيدا انه منذ نشاه العقيده
الصهيونيه كان هناك من اليهود من يقول هذا
مضاد للديانه اليهوديه لا تفعلوا هذا
بالديانه اليهوديه واضح ان هذا وبالتالي
كان هناك
معارضون اشداء منذ البدايه لفكر الدوله
قوميه لليهود سواء في فلسطين او غير
فلسطين وظلت هذه المعارضه لكي نراها الان
في مواقف شديده
الوضوح سواء بقى جماعيه
[موسيقى]
كالمظله يا معالي الدكتور هو كلام حضرتك
يعني تصديقا لكلام حضرتك انه ما حدث هو
امتداد ل فكره كانت مطروحه او توجهات كانت
مطروحه في
ناس
بيعرضوا ما يجري في غزه او في العمليات
السابقه من قبيل التعاطف والدفاع عن حقوق
الانسان وفي تيار اخر ناصر لاسرائيل ورافض
ما يجري في غزه حفاظا على امن اسرائيل انه
شايف انه ممارسات الحكومات المتطرفه هتدي
في نهايه المطاف الى ا يعني تاكل وضعف
اسرائيل والعدوان عليها وعدم وانها تكون
في موقف يصعب ان هو يتم الدفاع عليه او
التعاطف معاه يعني وهذا يذكرني بما سبق ان
ذكرته في هذه الحلقه من انه داخل اسرائيل
بدانا نشهد عددا متزايدا من المقالات التي
تنتقد السياسه التي تستخف باسرائيل وتتم
للحديث عن الراي العام العالمي والارهاصات
الجديده فيه انا اقول ارهاصات لاني لا
ادعي انه انقلب لكن هذه بدايات وفي يعني
انا لم اتتبع بعد ما يحدث داخل اوساط شباب
الحزب الديمقراطي في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لكن لفتني افتتاحيه توماس
فريدمان منذ ايام اللي هي جوهرها انه يا
اسرائيل لو ظننت انك تستطيعين فقط
الاكتفاء بتدمير غزه هذا محال لابد ان
تفعلي ما تريدين ان تفعليه ومعك سله ده حل
سياسي فالعالم بدا يفهم هذا وكان توماس
فريدمان واحد من الاشخاص اللي انا كانوا
في ذهني انا اشير الى انه واحد من
الحريصين جدا هو طبعا راجل يهودي وهو يعني
ما تقدرش تشكك في رغبته في الح حفاظ على
سلامه اسرائيل لكنه رجل عاقل يعني لا يمكن
ان تحتفظي بالسلام والهدوء في ظل اصرارك
على العدوان على الفلسطينيين وموضوع موقف
اليهود الامريكيين
وشخص زي توماس موضوع شديد الاهميه لان بعض
التصرفات الحمقاء بدا معها وكان هذا صراع
ديني واعتقد يعني بلينكن عندما ذهب
لاسرائيل جئت كيهودي
نعم بالضبط لا يعني ليس الى هذا الحد فان
يكون هذا موقف يهود شرفاء في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه اعتقد ان وزنهم ليس
بالقليل هذا مهم جدا ل تكذيب الصبغه
الدينيه لهذا الصراع نحن امام حاله
استعماريه واضحه استغلت الدين اليهودي من
اجل تحقيق اهدافها جزيل الشكر معالي
الدكتور ومع يعني تطور
الاحداث تنجال الصوره وتصبح اكثر وضوحا في
الاسابيع المقبله انا اشكر حضرتك وان شاء
الله اللقاءات موصوله لمتابعه ما يجري في
الاراضي المحتله وفي غيرها من الدول
العربيه شكرا يا استاذ سيد شكرا جزيلا
لحضراتكم والى لقاء اخر باذن الله